as governors across the country ramp up
restrictions ahead of thanksgiving our
next guest says
his state texas will not shut down
join us right now with an update texas
republican governor greg
abbott who is heralding the arrival of a
new coronavirus
anti-body treatment in the state as well
governor you got a lot going on don't
you
you know steve we have a lot going on
but i'm a little bit distracted because
i still have the image in my mind about
brian's
deltoid that he was talking about 30
minutes ago right well i'm just the only
one
i uh looking forward to the shot was my
point shot
that's the shot and and listen
the shot is coming steve going back to
your comment and
what we begin doing last week was we
begin the delivery
of these anti-body therapeutics the
first one that was delivered last week
is the one by eli lilly as you know over
the weekend
the regeneron antibody therapy the same
one that president
trump took has now been authorized for
emergency use we will soon begin
delivering that however
going back to the eli lilly one going to
all of these hot spots that we're seeing
in texas whether it be el paso or
lubbock and so many other places this
therapy is going to be available not
it's going to be is already available
we get weekly allotments where we are
increasing the amount of this antibody
therapy and what this does
is it allows people to recover as
quickly as what you saw the president
recover and what it will do is
it will keep people out of hospitals so
we will begin to see
hospitalizations decline you know
someone asked me recently that they they
said they had the antibodies and they
said do i still have to follow all the
restrictions as far as travel is
concerned since i've already
had it recovered and i have the
antibodies and i said good question
can you answer that for us so
when it comes to both the antibodies as
well as
the oncoming vaccines that as you saw
announced
will soon be delivered maybe as soon as
three weeks from now
it will allow people to be able to
travel or interact or
do common day activities without the
same concern
of getting coveted as would have existed
before these medicines became available
yeah i got a text message the other day
from blood banks saying if you know
anybody that had
has the antibodies they need them they
need them for treatment
haven't heard that in a while meanwhile
here are your current retraction
restrictions
in texas gatherings of more than 10
people prohibited in most circumstances
statewide mass order institute with some
exceptions
bars at 50 restaurants at 75 percent no
capacity limits on houses of worship
just keep your distance
know what you're doing governor you're
giving people
guidelines but you're not telling them
what to do you're saying this is the
best way to keep safe
but i don't want to destroy every
business in my state
why is that the better way to go
because brian along the course of
dealing with the pandemic we've all
learned
what works and what does not work and
one thing that
government does not need to do is to
micromanage the lives of everybody as
you point out
we set broad-based guidelines for people
to follow that lead to safe practices
without micromanaging it another thing
that i've made clear brian and that is
no more lockdowns in the state of texas
and i will tell you this
the the value that some people place
upon lockdowns
is misplaced if you lock people down
it's going to put them into confined
areas
where they can transmit covet just as
easily without
protocols and what we found in texas as
well as elsewhere
is one of the leading places where
people do transmit coveted are in these
private gatherings
so lockdowns are overvalued governor
before you go
the governor of oregon a woman by the
name of kate brown
says hey if you see anybody breaking any
of our state
suggestions and guidelines call the cops
is that the way
uh they should handle that call the cops
if you see somebody walking around with
no mask
i i got to tell you i think they may
have some fourth amendment based
challenges there but also i have to
point out the irony
if i understand correctly oregon just
legalized heroin and maybe cocaine
yes and so it's okay to have heroin and
cocaine but not turkey for thanksgiving
that is un-american it just does not
make sense
good point all right thank you so much
governor happy thanksgiving
you all too have very happy thanksgiving
thank you